i'm jeremiah bauman with the u.s
department of energy and today i'll be
answering your questions from twitter
this is energy support
[Music]
so at red sweet jones asks dog why is
gas so damn high i'm about to throw up
who isn't let's be honest uh it's very
very high and it's kind of a big problem
like so many things during the pandemic
production of oil and gas plummeted
because you know suddenly nobody was
driving anywhere for a few months back
there and then hardly driving for almost
a year year and a half so oil and gas
companies cut back production once
things started opening up planes are
flying again everyone's buying oil and
gas again but because production hadn't
caught up
prices went up and one that's kind of
going on right now is that oil and gas
companies are making way more money than
they've ever made before on oil and gas
and so they might be not quite so
inclined to increase production that
would bring prices down or do other
things that would bring prices down at
chris underscore ashworth asks does
geothermal heat mean diverting rivers of
molten lava into your home i am open to
this idea please advise as much as i
think we would all love a molten river
of lava side home geothermal heat means
drilling down into the ground and
tapping into the energy of the earth the
earth is naturally hot everywhere
basically they actually drill into the
earth much like they do for drilling for
oil and gas and the hot water comes up
and creates steam that can drive a
turbine and generate electricity at
princi sov asks how does electricity get
to the grid and then siphoned off to all
the homes and buildings to the end
consumer the grid is often described as
the biggest man-made machine on the
planet what it actually is is a giant
electrical circuit and it's literally a
bunch of wires connecting a power source
and it's circulating around you can
imagine each of these little stations is
a home or a business or a factory or
anything that needs electricity if you
close the circuit breaker and it creates
a loop that lets all these electrons
start circulating through this which is
electricity so the national grid is
actually broken up into lots of regional
and even local grids and the biggest
grid is mostly broken into three giant
sections it's called the western
interconnect and the eastern
interconnect and the third one is of
course independent-minded texas insisted
managing their own grid off on their own
with just a few connections to the rest
of us then within those regions states
or regions it gets broken down to the
even more local level so you've probably
seen in your neighborhood or off
somewhere in the field fenced in areas
they're just full of all this clearly
electrical equipment with massive wires
coming in right a lot of that equipment
is often what's called step down
transformers that take the power from
the massive grid that actually runs at a
different power level and breaks it down
to a lower power level for your
neighborhood and it's all one giant loop
that has to always stay connected has
step up transformers to take that power
level back up the other side of the
circle to feed it back to the bulk
transmission grid at the spirit of 77
asks but seriously do wind turbines
cause cancer or jobs or both okay
seriously wind turbines cause lots and
lots and lots of jobs and economic
development for counties and income for
farmers whose land they go on but they
do not cause cancer wind turbines super
cool they're these giant towers they
literally spin and generate electricity
they're not without controversy some
people don't want them and some states
are just going gangbusters iowa is going
to soon have enough wind power to meet
its entire electricity needs the high
plains states the dakotas kansas
nebraska is rapidly growing all these
states down to oklahoma and texas
generate tons and tons of electricity
from wind power already at micro dan
asks i am all in favor of green energy
so this is an honest question while evs
themselves have zero emissions when you
factor in the carbon emissions from the
generation of electricity how do they
compare to cars that run on fossil fuels
great question it is still cleaner to
charge your car on electricity and drive
it that way than it is to burn gasoline
in the tank the grid is way cleaner than
it was even five or ten years ago
electric motors are so much more
efficient you burn way less gas or coal
upstream to get enough electricity to
power a car than you do if you're trying
to actually explode gasoline right in
your car in order to get enough power to
drive at ken r stewart asks texas
produces almost 2 billion barrels of oil
a day why do texans have to pay so much
for their gas is it because big oil
dictates the prices at the pumps and not
government state and federal governments
need to step in and deal with big oil
gouging people one thing that makes the
united states different than a lot of
countries is the government does not set
the price for oil we don't even manage
how much gets produced or how much gets
consumed which some governments do those
are usually considered very aggressive
forms of government we like more of a
free market and so literally the market
decides how much we end up paying at the
end of the day it's a global market we
are competing at specific market places
with the entire planet with china with
saudi arabia with russia with europe
with south america literally everyone we
don't tell people how much oil to
produce there are things governments do
try to do the house representatives
passed a
bill to crack down on price gouging at
the pump how do you know when the local
gas station is charging more than they
should or if they're actually just
passing on costs from what they're
paying to get gasoline from 10 steps
upstream at the refiner so it is a
really hard question about the role of
government in society at john
lewis19212130 asks how is the strategic
oil reserve going to be replenished the
strategic petroleum reserve
this is a huge amount of oil that is
stored in a series of caverns
underground in louisiana and texas that
your department of energy owns and
manages as a strategic reserve basically
in case of emergency the average cavern
is deeper than the empire state building
is tall this president has actually
released more oil from the strategic
reserve than any president has before to
try to get the price of gasoline to come
down there's literally a million barrels
a day coming out of strategic petroleum
reserve in an effort to bring gas prices
down so we do need to replenish it
there's a couple different ways you can
do it one thing is we do sell the oil
when we release it from the reserve and
so the government is getting revenue
from selling all that oil we'd love to
turn around and use some of that revenue
to buy more oil once prices are nice and
low again which will hopefully be a day
that comes sooner rather than later to
fill the oil back up depending on how
all that plays out the way our funding
works is that every year congress
literally give the department of energy
enough money for its uh annual
operations including money to go out and
buy more oil if that's what we need to
do at rig chick asks nah bt dub how many
different types of renewable energy are
there there are five types of renewable
energy wind solar hydropower which comes
from rivers geothermal and marine or
tidal which comes from the movement of
ocean currents nationally we're
somewhere in the 20 renewable range
renewables are abundant and they're
cheap so everybody's trying to build
them fast and we should be pushing
utilities in the states to build faster
everywhere at mostafa18369324
asks in your opinion what is the best
renewable energy and why first of all
it's tempting to say solar because it's
getting
super cheap and it literally works
everywhere oregon known for being cloudy
and rainy could have so much more solar
power that it does it's not as cloudy
and radiant as germany and japan who
used to be totally kicking our butts in
solar power at fairy gray 19 would like
to know how does solar energy work solar
panels like this one here is like a tiny
i guess it's technically a toy but i
think it's actually a solar panel that
will actually generate electricity the
material on this panel which all starts
with silicon which is one of the most
abundant elements we've got it's made
from sand and when solar rays like
cosmic rays strike the material in the
solar panel it literally excites the
electrons in those atoms and it set up
there's little wires in there so the
electrons get channeled into wires and
then they're fed into electrical grid to
send those electrons as electricity all
the way to your home and fire your
appliances at general bullpu asks why is
crude oil so important in our lives when
we have better alternatives am i just
losing my mind here we do have better
alternatives for some things and we've
actually stopped using oil for some
things like if you look back in the 60s
and 70s we're using a lot of oil to burn
in power plants to generate electricity
there's this huge oil crisis that you
probably hear people talk about and we
did a huge concerted effort to get off
of oil used for electricity but it's
still everywhere and it's not just the
places that you most think of it right
like when you fill up your car with gas
you have a pretty good sense that came
directly from oil and you're kind of
just transferring barely changed oil
into your fuel tank there's some uses of
oil that we just don't have that many
alternatives for lots of the chemicals
that turn into things like plastics and
you can just imagine all the uses of
plastic throughout the society not just
in your day-to-day life there just
aren't alternatives that can make them
as cheaply and readably right now today
as we can by turning oil into plastics
at quad machine 09 asks so why is
nuclear power bad again i would argue
this nuclear power is one of our most
important forms of electricity if only
for one reason right now it's the single
biggest source of carbon-free
electricity meaning the kind of power
that does not cause global warming or
climate change and there are real
downsides to nuclear power and they're
serious right like people have heard
about chernobyl a massive nuclear
accident fukushima in japan just a few
years ago in a tsunami had a similar
problem where the nuclear reactor went
into disaster mode so the things you
have to solve for to make sure we have
reliable and safe nuclear power are
basically the risk of accidents some
kind of security like a terrorism attack
and then we put this nuclear fuel into a
nuclear reactor that again generates
steam that turns a turbine that creates
electricity it leaves nuclear waste that
itself is radioactive and it stays
radioactive for thousands of years so
how do you store it safely what most
nuclear power plants do is they keep it
on site it stays actually in cooling
ponds until it cools down until it's a
lot less dangerous and it gets
transferred into uh these dry casks and
it gets stored in a secure location on
site right now now we'd all like to get
that out of those locations and into
some more even further safe and secure
locations and that's actually one thing
the department of energy is working on
so at kingsley54272009
asks on a serious note what is natural
gas so imagine like a swamp with a bunch
of like decomposing plant and animal
matter in it millions of years of
sediment accumulating pushing all that
stuff down into the earth as that matter
uh decays it gives off natural gas or
methane it's often called it's cheaper
than coal and it's also cleaner than
coal when it comes to public health so
that's literally what natural gas is
it's also a huge source of energy in our
economy the problem is it's not without
downsides it still does create a fair
amount of pollution including carbon
dioxide one of the chief gases that
causes global warming or climate change
at mysticraven84 asks pardon my
ignorance here mate but how is fracking
clean energy number one what is fracking
it's actually short for hydraulic
fracturing it's where you drill into the
ground you literally like inject all
these fluids and chemicals to shatter
the rock underground to fracture it and
release the gas then comes back up it
gets called clean energy by some people
because it's a lot cleaner than coal but
it still causes climate change it still
causes other problems there's concerns
about it reaching water supplies in some
cases it's caused actually seismic
activity and earthquakes you know it's
probably better if we can find ways not
to inject things into the ground that
are going to contaminate groundwater but
it's an issue that people are going to
have to keep working on in some places
where there's fracking near populations
at a e i loves cats asks someone let me
know what an electric current is an
electric current is literally just
electrons moving through a charged
electrical field inside a conductor like
a wire
richard937-83516
asks thought of the day can anyone tell
me why the use of our rivers for green
energy never seems to be mentioned it's
what powered the first industrial
revolution in this country why don't we
use them now richard's right it did
power the first industrial revolution
that was actually a slightly different
form it was water that would turn wheels
that would actually just do the work
itself like you hear about grist mills
where literally the water is turning a
giant thing that's like grinding flower
or anything else that needs grinding why
don't we talk about it more today so
number one a lot of us do talk about it
a lot it's still a very commonly used
electricity source i think about 10 of
our electricity comes from hydropower of
our 20 total that is renewable about 10
half of it is hydropower and they
generate huge amounts of electricity
what you do in most cases you build a
dam that literally blocks the river and
these things that just spin when they
spin they generate electricity and it
goes downstream after it goes through
the turbines when you damn that river
there are some problems number one
salmon very cool animals they're born
way up in the mountains in little tiny
streams they migrate all the way down to
the ocean they swim hundreds and
hundreds of miles and at the end of
their lives they migrate all the way
back up the river all the way up to the
little creek they find the spot they
were born where they lay eggs and they
die unfortunately it kind of screws
everything up if they can't make that
migration we've invented lots of
technology to mitigate for that fish
ladders or some dams where there's like
literally a like suction thing inside
the reservoir and shoots the salmon out
back into the river below the dam we are
still working on hydropower and we still
invent invest in technology that makes
the dams less harmful for fish and if
you've got a dam that's already in place
but not drinking electricity we should
add electricity get some power from that
dam while it's gonna be there and we've
actually got a whole program at the
department of energy to help local
utilities do exactly that at
myself2677s can renewable energy sources
replace fossil fuels renewable energy
sources can replace most of fossil fuels
but with current technology not yet all
of course the wind doesn't always blow
and the sun doesn't always shine so when
that's not happening and you don't have
geothermal or hydropower available
locally where is your electricity going
to come from well today we get a bunch
of it from batteries actually it's a
small slug right now but it's growing
really rapidly fossil fuels can have a
future in all this too and they employ
millions of americans in america so we
want to research every option to keep
those jobs and those industries going so
it's called carbon capture and it
literally attaches to the emissions
coming off that place that the oil or
coal or gas is being burned and it
separates out the carbon dioxide that
otherwise cause global warming and then
it literally injects it deep underground
into salt caverns so that's the other
thing that we're working actively on is
another way to give us 24 7 100 clean
power
atom guillory asks imagine we all
somehow get electric cars and now need
to charge them how does the grid support
that and not become a massive liability
the grid goes down during a natural
disaster people have blackouts or
brownouts and now you're going to like
plug in millions of cars not only that
we're actually trying to switch
buildings and homes from using fossil
fuels for heat to using electricity for
heat so even more stuff plugging into
this grid that's why we need to not just
update and modernize the grid but at the
same time do two things number one build
out way more grid there's just not the
grid connections to get them to the
places that need more electricity so
just doing that is going to help a ton
the other kind of really cool thing here
is that a lot of these technologies like
electric vehicles can actually have the
grid work in both ways meaning the car
charges when it needs to fill up its
battery but if it's plugged in and it
doesn't need more electricity it's a
giant battery connected to the grid so
you can actually set it up so that at
certain times of day the utility can
just draw a little bit of power from
thousands of vehicles the bottom line is
we just need to build a lot more power
grid to power this new future that's
going to have electric vehicles electric
buildings we're going to try to switch
as many things as we can onto the grid
so we need more grid at pelham fall asks
i do wonder what the macroeconomic
impacts would be of a complete phase-out
of using gasoline for vehicles
like what does zofik do after that so
opec organization of petroleum exporting
countries dominated by saudi arabia the
biggest opec producer and their middle
eastern allies and then countries like
russia and venezuela actively work with
them to jointly reduce how much oil
they're selling to drive prices up or
sometimes they'll release more
when prices get too high the problem is
the u.s is actually the number one
producer of oil and gas in the world and
we have millions of people who work in
that industry so it also would affect
jobs and that's why one big thing we try
to work on is how do you find jobs and
create jobs people that work in oil and
gas in technologies like geothermal and
other renewable energy technologies so
we minimize any harm to build
livelihoods at the same time that we're
getting that huge economic boost from no
longer buying gasoline at post 0341
asks i'm still yet to hear detailed
explanation of how the paris accords
either help or hurt earth or economy
based on technicalities of treaty the
paris accords were a huge epic historic
deal literally at this point every
country is part of a global agreement to
tackle global warming and how we're
going to reduce emissions
and then every country has to submit its
own plan for the specific steps that
we're going to take to do it so the u.s
has a whole plan for this and it breaks
it down by every part of the economy
here's how much clean energy we're going
to build whether that's renewable energy
or fossil with carbon capture or nuclear
here's how we're going to deploy
electric vehicles a whole plan a plan
for five years from now for 10 years
from now and for 2050 and then every
year
all these governments meet and hash out
who's doing what and how are we getting
through all this and how's it going how
do we take advantage of the clean energy
getting cheaper to set higher goals and
it's literally going to be the whole
world working together every country
sitting at a table
every year for the next 40 years and
even then we're going to have to keep
working because climate change is that
big of a problem